it's a health workers nightmare a busy
border crossing thousands of people in
close contact and constantly on the move
this medical worker tells people to wash
their hands health checks and hygiene
measures have tightened between the
Democratic Republic of Congo and Rwanda
ever since multiple cases of the Ebola
virus were discovered here in Goma the
Congolese city of more than two million
people people are washing their hands as
a precaution due to the outbreak of
disease the telus that is spreading
through the hands that's why they are
asking us to wash with water mixed with
medication the virus is passed through
bodily fluids including sweat there is a
vaccine that has been used for quite
some time the World Health Organization
says it has a very high success rate and
you only need one shot but there's a
problem the vaccination is not approved
for mass use it's usually given to those
exposed to the virus and it's also given
to the doctors and health workers as
they are handling those cases to protect
them from contracting the virus there is
still no officially approved Ebola
vaccine on the market but we're told
this one is expected to be officially
approved at some stage there is also a
lot of confusion around the virus and a
lot of suspicion of foreign health
workers here in eastern DRC it's a
remote region that has been neglected by
the government and torn apart by years
of conflict it would have been better if
our leaders and those who are concerned
would give us more information they have
not informed us where we can get this
vaccine so that all of us can go and
actually get it but for sure all of us
need to be vaccinated this is the second
worst Ebola outbreak on record more than
a thousand 800 people have died of the
virus in the DRC over the past year but
the fact that it has now reached a
border city is what's causing renewed
alarm it prompted the government here in
Rwanda to close its western border for a
few hours on Thursday as it beefed up
its health screening procedures are the
problem with this virus is once you
identify someone infected by it do they
need to trace back all the people they
have come in
contact with test them vaccinate them
and potentially quarantine them it is a
highly infectious disease and containing
it is a real challenge Stephanie Decker
al Jazeera Kigali